vamos a empezar con este sistema clásico
al cual me estado refiriendo en los
vídeos de termodinámica y digamos que
tengo este cilindro tiene un pequeño
pistón encima de él que es un techo que
se puede mover y que el gas que estamos
pensando dentro es un gas ideal mono
atómico y que está ejerciendo cierta
presión en el techo ok y la razón por la
cual el techo no se está moviendo es
porque tengo un montón de piedritas de
rocas en el que están ejerciendo una
presión hacia abajo es decir una fuerza
por mira de área y empiezo con este gas
en el equilibrio digamos que tiene
cierto volumen presión y que también
tiene una temperatura y esas tres están
bien definidas lo que voy a hacer ahora
es colocar este sistema aquí lo voy a
poner encima de un depósito de calor
digamos ya hablé un poco de eso en un en
vídeos anteriores y lo pueden pensar
como algún objeto infinitamente grande
que dé una cierta temperatura ok
entonces si lo ponemos encima de él
digamos que empiezo a mover
los granitos de piedra ajá y aprendimos
en algunos vídeos que si lo hacemos de
forma diabética si vamos quitando estas
piedritas el volumen incrementa la
presión baja y de hecho la temperatura
también baja y mostramos también en
algunos vídeos anteriores que al poner
este depósito aquí abajo
en realidad el sistema se mantiene a la
misma temperatura la temperatura de uno
y puedes pensar que este depósito
digamos por ejemplo no sé que tenemos
una taza con agua en un estadio y que en
el estadio hay aire acondicionado que
está a 60 grados bueno no importa lo que
haga con el agua verdad la puedo poner
en el horno de microondas calentarlo y
después no importa el estadio va a
seguir a 60 grados verdad y puedes
pensar bueno a lo mejor la temperatura
del depósito y baja pero es tan grande
que su impacto no se puede no se puede
notar ok por ejemplo la tasa de agua
hirviendo si la metemos en el estadio el
agua se va a volver más fría y el
ambiente del estadio realmente se va a
mantener igual ok
bueno en realidad es que no vamos a
notar algún cambio verdad y teóricamente
esto lo podemos hacer infinito de un
tamaño infinito entonces esto va a
mantener la temperatura constante y
recordemos qué
y eso va a mantener también va a
mantener la energía interna constante
entonces vamos a ver qué pasa si
seguimos quitando estas piedritas
llegamos a cierto punto ok
donde mi volumen ha incrementado así que
déjenme borrar algunas de estas piedras
ok vamos a borrar algunas de estas
piedras ya algunas se fueron ok y todo
mi volumen va a ser mayor
así que si movemos esto un poco hacia
arriba déjenme colorear esto de negro
también oops
aunque
que está ya lo ponemos de negro así que
nuestro volumen ha incrementado un poco
y ponerlo ya con la herramienta que
necesito entonces el volumen ha
aumentado bastante hasta esta altura y
tenemos que las partículas están
chocando cada vez con menor frecuencia
en el techo verdad por qué
aquí sí tenemos este depósito durante
todo este tiempo la temperatura se ha
mantenido a 1 a 1 verdad y eso es por el
depósito de calor que teníamos y por
supuesto esto es un proceso cuasi
estático porque lo estamos haciendo muy
muy lento el sistema está siempre en un
equilibrio que se va cambiando poco a
poco
así que vamos a dibujar nuestro famoso
diagrama de presión volumen
aunque digamos este es el eje de de la
presión de la p
este es el eje del volumen
vamos a etiquetarlos en el tape
y déjenme llamar a este vamos a hacerlo
en otro color vamos a poner este el
estado a es del estado de del sistema
así que el estado a digamos así esta
cierta presión y volumen por ahí ok y se
mueve al estado b y noten que como como
estoy manteniendo la temperatura
constante como vimos en el vídeo
anterior bueno esto se va a recorrer
hasta el estado ve a lo largo de la
historia que es una hipérbola verdad
porque cuando la temperatura es
constante la presión por el volumen es
constante y eso simplemente es el
recorrido de una hipérbole entonces
digamos que se mueve de esta forma el
estado ve
ok voy a moverme al estado ve aquí
y todo el tiempo tenemos la misma
temperatura de 1
ahora hemos hecho un montón de vídeos
hasta ahora en donde decimos que bueno
cuánto trabajo generamos que es hoy
realmente el área debajo de la curva así
que tiene a lo mejor algún trabajo
positivo baja porque nos movemos en
dirección digamos hacia la derecha
porque hay de izquierda a derecha y el
trabajo que realizamos es
sería sería el área debajo de esta curva
ok
el área debajo de la curva realizado por
el sistema desde a hasta b entonces el
trabajo desde a hasta le vamos a denotar
lo así ok de todo eso está bien pero lo
que quiero pensar es también cuánto
calor transferimos al sistema y
recordemos que como este este depósito
siempre está a temperatura de 1 eso hace
que el sistema se mantenga la misma
temperatura y bueno sea fácil responder
cuánto calor hemos agregado porque el
cambio en la energía interna es igual al
calor agregado
- el trabajo realizado por el sistema
ahora cuál es el cambio en la energía
interna bueno como la temperatura es
constante todo el tiempo entonces y
bueno además es un gas ideal y todos los
demás que ya hemos hablado entonces la
temperatura interna es más bien la
temperatura del sistema no cambia es
decir la energía cinética tampoco cambia
y por lo tanto la energía interna -
cambia
y entonces realmente tenemos que el
cambio es cero y eso es igual al calor
menos el trabajo realizado por el
sistema muy bien de aquí podemos
concluir que el calor que agregamos es
igual es igual al trabajo realizado por
el sistema del estado a al estado b y
tiene sentido verdad el sistema estaba
haciendo cierto trabajo todo este tiempo
y estaba cediendo energía bueno ya saben
no estaba cediendo esencialmente energía
a las rocas a través de energía
potencial y estaba dando energía hacia
afuera así que para que la energía
interna se mantenga
tengo que darle energía y eso se hace a
través de calor ok y que es a través de
este depósito que está temperatura de 1
ok entonces aquí lo podemos ejemplificar
con una flecha y le ponemos el kun o
esto esto está indicando que hay cierta
energía que le estamos metiendo al
sistema muy bien entonces ahora vámonos
de este sistema ve
ok y vamos a quitar el depósito de calor
ok
así que no hay forma en que el calor
pueda transferirse al sistema y quitemos
aún más piedras ok
seguimos quitando más piedritas ya dónde
llegamos
déjenme ponerlo aquí digamos que
seguimos quitando un buen de roquetas y
déjenme desquitar todavía más de estas
rocas que teníamos en ve
porque quizás sólo nos quedamos con una
y obviamente el volumen total habrá
incrementado un buen ok déjenme poner
que este pistón ha subido ya bastante
digamos todo esto mucho más alto ahora
ok déjenme rellenar esto con un color
negro solo para que no se vea un espacio
ahí vacío verdad ok
déjenme rellenar
ok
ya está ahí relleno debería usar usar
debería usar el azul para
quitar esto esto parece más clase de
dibujo más que de termodinámica verdad
pero bueno no importa agregamos las
partículas que sean necesarias
entonces mi presión habrá bajado porque
ya las partículas chocan menos con los
muros y debido a esto el volumen también
incrementó pero qué le pasó a la
temperatura mi temperatura va a bajar
verdad porque todo esto fue un proceso a
diabético y en un proceso a diabético
que eso significa que está aislado el
sistema no hay un intercambio de calor
hacia afuera ni hacia adentro entonces
déjenme conectar estos sistemas con esta
con esta marca que dice a diabético y
ahora como nos estamos moviendo a otra
temperatura de 2 digamos que llegamos a
cierta temperatura de 2 entonces nos
movemos a otra isoterma esta es la
isoterma correspondiente a la
temperatura de 1 es decir esta hipérbola
corresponde a que a lo largo de esa la
temperatura es constante y este 1 pero
ahora nos movemos a otra temperatura a
otra isoterma digamos que aquí tengo la
isoterma de 2 que se vea digamos algo
así
ok debería acordar la un poco más verdad
para que se vea
hipérbola así que digamos que esta es la
temperatura t 2 es decir la presión y el
volumen se conservan perdón presión y
volumen conservan una temperatura de 2 a
lo largo de esa curva y entonces si
bajamos bajamos del estado ve a otro
estado sé que es este último que pinte
ok entonces quién sabe cómo se mueve
déjenme lo hago con otro color
ok pues con este color naranja entonces
nos movimos quién sabe cómo pero
llegamos a un estado c ok esto fue un
proceso a diabético
ok que significa que no hay intercambio
de calor con él con el medio exterior
así que no tenemos calor que lo
transferimos ni hacia fuera ni hacia
adentro sin embargo aún realizamos
trabajo ok
podemos tomar el área debajo de esta
curva y vamos a dejarlo para futuros
vídeos como como cómo podemos hacer esto
es decir cuánto reducimos a través la
energía a través de trabajo pero bueno
nuestra energía interna se redujo porque
la temperatura bajó así que la energía
interna se reduce
y ahora estamos en un estado ce
correspondiente a la temperatura de 2
vamos a poner otro otro cilindro aquí ok
vamos a poner solo lo voy a copiar y
pegar pero este cilindro lo que va a
tener es un depósito que déjenme poner
estos dos aquí
ok entonces este cilindro vamos a
agregarle o más bien vamos a borrar
estas estas piedras de aquí arriba
y vamos a borrarle muchas de estas y
vamos a ahora agregar unos bloques de
estos ok es decir estamos en el estado
ce y vamos a ir agregando bloques ok de
forma isotérmica es decir vamos a tener
que agregar un depósito aquí
no es el mismo depósito que teníamos del
proceso a albe va a ser otro otro nuevo
depósito y va a tener una temperatura
distinta déjenme poner lo mejor en azul
porque
aquí que está ocurriendo ahora estoy
agregando granitos de arena y estoy
comprimiendo el gas si esto fuera un
proceso diabético entonces la
temperatura subiría lo que estoy
haciendo es poner este depósito de calor
en la temperatura de dos dedos para que
este proceso sea isotérmico entonces
pueden ver que realmente es este un
depósito frío
así que puedes imaginar que el calor
generado en el sistema o la energía
interna generada bueno no debería
decirlo así sino que la temperatura del
sistema va a querer subir porque se está
liberando
a través del depósito y eso es una
cantidad q2 verdad
así que nos movemos a lo largo de esto
ok a través de un proceso isotérmico a
lo largo de esta curva isoterma ok hasta
que lleguemos al estado d
ya estamos casi ahí
este es el estado de
así que el estado de va a estar a lo
mejor en algún lugar en esta en esta
curva y ahí por ejemplo y otra vez
podemos tener el argumento de que nos
movemos a lo largo de esta curva
isoterma porque no daríamos la
temperatura ok entonces sabemos que la
energía interna que fue debe hace
el cambio pero desea de no va a cambiar
porque mantenemos la temperatura fija y
de hecho la temperatura este 2 porque
teníamos este depósito aquí ahora si tu
temperatura se mantiene igual entonces
la energía también se mantiene igual al
menos en este en este tipo de procesos
que de hecho es el tipo de procesos más
clásicos en los cursos de termodinámica
entonces dada una energía interna
aplicamos el mismo argumento de que el
calor agregado al sistema es igual al
trabajo hecho por el sistema es la misma
las mismas matemáticas que hicimos la
vez pocas anterior pero en este caso el
trabajo hecho es hacia el sistema es
decir comprimimos el pistón al agregar
granitos de arena así que el trabajo fue
hecho hacia el sistema ok
simplemente estamos aplicando la misma
idea donde nuestra energía interna no
cambio es decir la delta es igual a cero
y por lo tanto q es igual a w ave
el calor agregado al sistema será
negativo
otra forma de pensarlo es que el sistema
libero calor no si el sistema libero
calor es porque es negativo y ponemos
una q 2 aquí donde donde obtuvo donde
liberó escudos pues a través de la del
depósito frío ajá que está aceptando el
calor del sistema ya casi llegamos ahora
digamos que quitamos este depósito del
sistema otra vez y está otra vez aislado
ok entonces empezamos en el estado de
seguimos agregando granitos de arena
hasta llegar de nuevo al estado
y seguimos agregando los granitos y
regresamos al estado
muy bien entonces este es este es el
proceso vamos bebé al punto déjenme
hacerlo con otro color
vamos a hacerlo con este verde entonces
si seguimos agregando granitos de arena
llegamos nuevamente a través de un
proceso a diabético
desde aaa pero vamos en sentido
contrario verdad entonces un par de
cosas interesantes que podemos rescatar
de aquí es que como suponemos un
escenario ideal no hay pérdida de
fricción y entonces el pistón
simplemente se mueve hacia arriba o
hacia abajo porque no se pierde calor y
también podemos decir que hemos
alcanzado nuestra energía interna
original de hecho esta es una de las
propiedades de este experimento que
hemos hecho y que se refleja en el
diagrama de presión volumen verdad
tenemos la misma presión el mismo
volumen la misma temperatura que como
empezamos así que hemos completado un
ciclo y este ciclo en particular que es
muy importante y que se llama el ciclo
de carnota se llama es llamado así
debido al ingeniero francés carbón ok
que estaba buscando cosas
cómo poder optimizar algunos algún
funcionamiento de algunos motores vamos
a tratar de entender realmente lo que es
la entropía a través de estos ejemplos
porque se utiliza mucho en las clases de
química y bueno es a veces hasta difícil
definirlo o incluso medirlo y lo que
vamos a hacer es tratar de entender los
primeros conceptos de entropía de cómo
vienen y cómo se relacionan con moderna
con nociones modernas de ella ahora un
sistema que completa un ciclo de carne
es llamado en una máquina de carne así
que nuestro pequeño pistón aquí está
moviéndose hacia arriba y hacia abajo y
tú podrías decir oye esto no parece como
una gran máquina verdad y la verdad es
que tendría razón realmente no es es es
una máquina útil en un sentido teórico
porque nos permite entender cómo el
calor se transfiere a una máquina y guía
de y quiero quiero adentrarme más en
esta idea del cilindro al que se le
transfiere cierto calor y que existe el
sistema también transfiere calor hacia
afuera de una forma más pequeña verdad
del otro depósito así que este sistema
estaba le estaban transfiriendo calor a
través del primer depósito de una de un
depósito muy caliente al sistema y en el
proceso después que fue lo que ocurrió
pues que realizó un trabajo que de hecho
es el área debajo del del ciclo verdad o
más bien dentro del ciclo en este es el
trabajo realizado por la máquina de
carne y la forma de pensar esto es que
cuando vamos de ave es calculamos el
área debajo de esa curva después de
verse también hacemos lo mismo y cuando
hacemos de c a d en realidad hay que
quitar área de hecho también desde a en
realidad estamos quitando área porque
vamos en un sentido contrario ok
entonces en realidad estamos tomando
estamos empezando digamos tenemos aquí
nuestro depósito de 1
hoy tenemos el depósito t1 y después
tenemos aquí nuestra máquina que puede
ser un motor por ejemplo y que está
conectado también bueno uno es el calor
que se transfiere desde t1 y genera
cierto trabajo ok y este trabajo se
representa por la cantidad o el área
dentro de nuestro ciclo y también lo
transfiere a q2 que es esencialmente un
depósito frío aunque entonces aquí
tenemos la temperatura
de 2 y transfiere un calor q2 ok la
diferencia entre 1 y q2 puedes ver que
si tenemos más calor viniendo que el que
se sale
entonces si genera un trabajo
literalmente entonces uno menos q 2 es
igual al trabajo que realizó ok y de
hecho este es un buen momento para
enfatizar que el calor y el trabajo no
son variables de estado verdad las
variables de estado tienen que tener la
misma
el mismo valor a lo largo de cuando es
cuando estamos en el equilibrio
realmente aquí estamos hablando de
trabajo hecho o calor inyectado al
sistema y no es una propiedad inherente
de una variable de estado inherente al
sistema no podemos decir ah mira el
sistema tiene tanto calor tanto trabajo
si no son cantidades que se agregan o se
quitan de del sistema o también
podríamos hablar del trabajo que fue
hecho para o por el sistema de cualquier
forma los quiero dejar con eso hasta
ahorita vamos a estudiar esto mucho más
pero la parte importante es que no te
confundas con esto en termodinámica te
invito a que incluso hagas este mismo
vídeo tú mismo es decir que agarres
papel y lápiz y hagas exactamente todo
igual para que comprendas realmente el
concepto de la máquina de carnet que
vamos a utilizarlo también que entiendan
los procesos a diabéticos los hizo
térmicos entendiendo eso va a ser mucho
más fácil entender el concepto de
entropía mucho más intuitivo y sobre
todo no tan confuso